the Joe Rogan experience do you have a
long-term vision in terms of what you're
trying to do with virtual reality and
oculus so I do and it's I'm you know
it's something that people some people
read this the wrong way and react
incorrectly to it where I've said that
my pitch for VR is that the promise of
VR is it's to make the world as you want
it where people do not have the it's
just it is not possible on earth to be
able to give everybody all that they
would want not everybody can have
Richard Branson's private island there's
just not enough private amount of
islands in the world to give them to
people but even on a much more mundane
level not everyone can have a mansion of
a house not everyone can even
necessarily have a home theater room and
these are things that we can simulate to
some degree in virtual reality
now the simulations not as good as the
real thing again if you are rich and you
have your own home theater and mansion
and private island good for you i we may
still be able to offer you the
convenience of being able to
instantaneously get to different places
but you're still probably not the people
that are going to benefit most from it I
but most of the people in the world
aren't in that position most of the
people in the world live in relatively
clamped quarters that are not what they
would choose to be if they had unlimited
resources and the technology curves for
these things are this is $400 now we
have an earlier one that's $200 that's
less capable but these follow the
cellphone price curves in many ways we
have $25 cell phones in India now that
are smartphones that do a lot of these
things the technology curve Moore's law
may be crapping out in terms of absolute
performance but we've still got a lot of
price performance that we can drive out
of these things and we can have virtual
reality devices that can get cheap
enough that lots and lots of people will
be able to have these and we can make
better and better software and it can be
a better world in many ways now people
everybody points towards like there's
this art piece of art that goes around
the internet of this sort of dystopian
kid in the corner drew you know drooling
with glass goggles on with rainbow
pictures on them and it's a terrible
looking place and people say it's like
oh this is the world you're
trying to build people plugged into
virtual reality that ignore the world
around them
and of course the first rejoinder to
that is well is his life really better
if he takes them off and he's in this
horrible place there but more concretely
like I just came from in Dallas it's a
hundred degrees this week there we
changed the world around us in all that
we do we live in air-conditioning and
people nowadays don't generally go oh
you're not experiencing the world around
you because of your air conditioning you
should be out there really experiencing
the world now that is what human beings
do is we you know we bend the world
through our will and I think that a
virtual reality that lets people do
things that would not be possible in the
world or it comes down to it not
economical and a lot of people react
negatively to any talk about economics
but it is resource allocation I am you
know you have to make decisions about
where things go and I think that
economically we can deliver more value
to a lot of people in this virtual sense
we're at the very earliest stage of it
right now with the experiences that we
have and the things you can do and how
long you want to keep it on but there is
a path to this comfortable thing that
you can wear for hours at a time maybe
you spend your entire workday working in
it maybe your time after coming home is
putting it on and I mean right now you
can you can watch TV with someone else
in virtual reality which is this mundane
thing but you can have AI you know your
sister or somebody that's across the
country and you can have meet in a
virtual space look over and see each
other and you know watch something on TV
like all activities that do not require
an actual tactile physical thing can
eventually be subsumed in this where
there are a lot of things that do
require the tactile stuff you're not
going to be replacing food with virtual
reality anytime soon but a surprising
amount of things that people value are
these largely audio-visual things it's
the decoration the museum that you walk
through
you're not fondling the individual
things they're you're experiencing
things in a way that could with a
good-enough virtual reality experience
be replicated there without the travel
without the lines without the crowds you
could have it private to yourself and
there's so many things like this it's
not everything it's two of your senses
simulated fair
well but we can do an enormous amount
with this and I always like internally
I'm almost a broken record in the
company most people are tired of hearing
me harp about this but it's all about
user value you know what I care about
building things as an engineer the whole
point is to bring value to the world and
I think that virtual reality can bring a
lot of value we're not there yet we're
in very early days of there are certain
niches of people today that can get a
great value out of this I don't pretend
that this is something that you know
everyone in the world can benefit from
today but we're inching our way up
towards that and that's how you know
that's how the world gets better is by
building technologies and distributing
to the people so that they have
something better than they would have
had if that didn't exist
[Applause]